-Welcome back.
I am here with Ken Jeong.
And since Halloween
is this weekend,
Ken and I are about to play
a spooky game.
It's time for a "Tonight Show"
"Freaky Face-Off."
-♪ Freaky ♪
-♪ Face-off ♪
-Alright.
Now, here's how this works.
Right here in our Zoom window,
we are going to show you
a freaky face.
It could be a Halloween mask,
it could be a jack-o'-lantern,
but it is going to be scary.
And then we're going to
take turns
trying to re-create that
freaky face live.
Sound good?
-Sounds great.
-Alright, here we go.
First freaky face is for you.
Check it out.
[ Thunder crashes ]
Alright.
Ken, try to re-create the face.
[ Thunder crashes ]
Terrifying.
That was really good, actually.
I like it.
Alright. Alright. Here we go.
Now it is my turn.
Here we go.
-Okay.
[ Thunder crashes ]
Okay. That's the face?
This way?
[ Thunder crashes ]
-Oh, my God. Oh, my God.
Someone give him
some caffeine, stat.
[ Both laugh ]
-I can probably
do better than that.
I don't know.
-A sleepy zombie! Oh, no!
-So, his mouth is down.
Wait. His mouth is down.
Can I try it one more time?
-Yeah, yeah. Yeah.
-Alright.
Like that, and then...
[ Thunder crashes ]
-Oh, my God.
You look like Joel McHale
when he's drowsy.
[ Both laugh ]
-Ken, it is your turn.
It is your turn again.
Here we go.
[ Thunder crashes ]
Ooh!
Dude, I want a doll
that looks like that.
[ Both laugh ]
Okay, let's see.
-What am I doing?
-Okay, here we go.
[ Thunder crashes ]
Okay.
-Well, time to eat your
running shoe, Jimmy.
[ Both laugh ]
-That's how I unlock my iPhone.
I put my foot on it.
5-You put your foot on it.
-It reads my foot, and no one
else can open my iPhone.
And, actually,
that's how I open my doors is,
I put my foot in it.
Oh, God. Sorry.
This last one is for both of us.
So we'll both have to
match this freaky face.
Let's see it.
[ Thunder crashes ]
Okay, ready?
1, 2, 3...
Oh, my God.
[ Thunder crashes ]
-You damn kids.
You damn kids step on my face!
You damn kids.
-My thanks to Ken Jeong.